Dieser Mann sorgt dafür,
dass Stricken und Gestricktes
immer beliebter werden:
Stephen West,
gebürtiger US-Amerikaner, 32 Jahre alt.
Seine farbenfrohen Strickmuster
begeistern vor allem Jüngere und Männer.
Die Designs und Muster
stammen alle von mir.
Ich entwerfe und stricke jedes Muster
und schreibe die Anleitung.
Da steckt viel Leidenschaft drin,
und ich mag es wirklich sehr, was ich mache.
Besonders gerne arbeite ich
mit ganz vielen Farben.
Farbe inspiriert mich am meisten.
Auf Instagram hat der in Amsterdam lebende
Strickdesigner rund 225.000 Follower.
In seinen Online-Tutorials zeigt er,
wie man seine bunten
geometrischen Muster selbst stricken kann.
Humor und Unterhaltung spielen
in seinen Clips eine wichtige Rolle.
Ich möchte noch viele weitere
lustige Video-Tutorials drehen,
sodass ganz viele Menschen
Lust aufs Stricken bekommen.
Und die Videos müssen auch
nicht immer so technisch sein.
Sie können auch spielerisch
und modisch sein.
Seine Muster entwirft der gelernte Tänzer
und Choreograph zunächst als Skizze.
Dann übernehmen er
und sein Team die Ausarbeitung.
Mittlerweile genießt Stephen West Kultstatus
und hat Fans auf der ganzen Welt.
Regelmäßig veröffentlicht er Bücher
mit seinen Strickanleitungen.
Er hat eine eigene Wollmarke gegründet
und ist Mitinhaber eines Wollgeschäfts
in Amsterdam.
Ich halte mich nicht gerne an die Regeln
und stricke auch nicht nach den Regeln.
Ich war nie auf einer Designschule oder so
und habe mir das alles
sehr spielerisch aufgebaut.
Der 13-jährige Berliner Konstantin Siebeck
zählt zu den Fans von Stephen West.
Das Stricken hat ihm seine Oma beigebracht.
Ideen und Anregungen findet er
online bei Ravelry.
Das soziale Netzwerk hat sich
auf Handarbeiten spezialisiert
und weltweit rund 9 Millionen Mitglieder.
Ich war einfach fasziniert,
was man mit Stricken machen kann,
weil ich dachte ja eigentlich,
dass irgendwie Stricken was für Omas ist,
aber so ist es eigentlich gar nicht.
Auch der 39-jährige Fabian Fiedler aus Berlin
hat das Stricken für sich entdeckt.
Der Pianist, der eine Musikschule betreibt,
hat schon rund 100 Werke selbst gestrickt,
darunter Pullover, Schals, Mützen,
Socken und Decken.
Stricken ist für mich 'ne pure Leidenschaft,
und ich stricke wahnsinnig gerne,
weil ich dann mich abends nach 'nem
langen Arbeitstag
einfach aufs Sofa setzen kann,
mach' mir den Kamin an
und genieß' diesen Moment der Ruhe
und kann meinen Fokus auf eine Sache legen
und alles andere drumrum vergessen
und ausschalten.
Aber nicht nur Selbstgemachtes
liegt im Trend:
In den aktuellen Modekollektionen der Herren
ist Strick in allen Variationen zu finden.
Ob bunt gemustert,
Oversize oder ganz schlicht –
an Strickmode kommt man
in dieser Saison nicht vorbei.
Das kann auch Sascha Uetrecht bestätigen.
Der Berliner führt seit vielen Jahren
ein Wollgeschäft.
Aber nicht nur das:
Er organisiert regelmäßig
Strickreisen und Strick-Events,
wie zum Beispiel Strickkreuzfahrten.
Aufgrund der Pandemie finden
seine Veranstaltungen derzeit nur digital statt,
wie sein wöchentliches Online-Strick-Meeting.
Anfangs hatte ich dann
Facebook-Live-Shows gemacht,
konnte aber nur einseitig agieren
mit den Kunden.
Und dann dachte ich: Ha, da gibt's ja auch
noch Zoom und andere Plattformen.
Aber auf Zoom habe ich
dann halt wirklich gemerkt,
ich kann interagieren,
ich kann mit den Leuten sprechen,
ich kann sie was fragen,
sie können mir antworten,
ich kann denen was zeigen,
wir können was entwickeln,
oder wir können einfach nur Spaß haben
und schnacken dabei, ne?
Zurück nach Amsterdam zu Stephen West:
Sein Geschäft im Herzen der
niederländischen Hauptstadt
ist bereits etabliert.
Und an kreativen Ideen für die Zukunft
mangelt es ihm nicht.
Ich könnte mir eine eigene Talkshow
im Fernsehen vorstellen,
mit vielen Tanzeinlagen.
Wir könnten neue Techniken lernen
und ein paar Tutorials zeigen.
Ich könnte alle meine Freunde interviewen.
Das wäre verrückt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Welt dafür bereit ist.
Stricken –
eine erfolgreiche Masche,
die auf dem Weg ist,
auch eine Männersache zu werden.